how did you capture the tone like as
directors because I want to go there's a
lot of artists in the room tonight you
know filmmakers and writers how did you
capture the tone like you know what I
mean like you know cuz the movie has a
beautiful tone and you're the guy who is
guiding the ship and you're directing
all the players how what does that
process how do you get a tone how did
you get this tone you know I couldn't
tell you because I don't really know
it's totally instinctual it is not
intellectual and I haven't written a lot
of note when I gave my stuff to the
Academy I said well there's nothing here
I didn't write any notes you know on the
scripts here's the scripts but so my
prime I've never dissected my process I
just try to be in the moment as and get
out of the way not control but kind of
draw out of the kids or the people the
actors who are giving you know giving
their guts and I just let it happen I
just kind of moved people in the right
direction let them talk to each other
and I get out of the way I don't try to
direct I try to collaborate in a way you
know Michael it's the best direction in
it I mean it's honestly we've been
friends forever I'm you know we dig each
other we cool in and I'll pay back that
$5 soon I promise
you know but know what you did a lot
with myself and Glenn you know mostly it
so you would just kind of give us a pin
point and you let us be but we had
they're comfortable we felt comfortable
enough to stay honest and to let
ourselves just go for it
and not be inhibited to just be open or
loose or even silly you gave us freedom
you know and you didn't on you didn't
pounce it you didn't dictate and we
never felt you always have a car man
you have until this day till this day
I've never heard you curse til this day
I'm I don't know if he do it at home but
I've never heard it and of course I
would never worry I've got you back no
he does not
yes I do he has never said but different
flavours so so so who knows you know
it's like I I i try to find really good
people good actors so i don't have to
work too hard and just just let him go
let him play you know and if that's what
you feel you know if the tone or the the
scene is not going right i just kind of
drop a suggestion you know